[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis schönen guten abend zum
ende der woche das wichtigste vom sport
von norbert könig ja ein bisschen später
und die wichtigsten nachrichten jetzt im
überblick
makro oder le pen stichwahl um die
präsidentschaft in frankreich
angriffe auch am orthodoxen osterfest
die ukraine kündigt den besuch von us
ministern an
und rekordsieger thw kiel die
norddeutschen gewinnen gegen magdeburg
zum zwölften mal den handball pokal
der liberale amtsinhaber immer nur im
makro oder die extrem rechte marine le
pen in frankreich entscheiden heute die
wahlberechtigten wer künftig im
elysée-palast sitzt und damit den kurs
des landes bestimmt nicht nur in
frankreich sondern in ganz europa schaut
man mit spannung auf den ausgang der
wahl in knapp einer stunde schließen die
letzten wahllokale am abend über das
finale rennen
er tritt an für eine zweite amtszeit
frankreichs präsident manual makro will
das land weiter reformieren setzt sich
für ein starkes europa ein in umfragen
lag er zuletzt vorn doch das land ist
gespalten so viel schon viel zu lange
sind die extrem rechten präsent in
frankreich und machen uns angst weil sie
abermals in die stichwahl gekommen sind
ich drücke die daumen für makro
penn als präsidentin würde frankreich in
den mittelpunkt stellen sie ist
nationalistisch und gegen ein europa wie
wir es heute erleben ich bin überhaupt
nicht mit ihr einverstanden
marine le pen gab am vormittag ihre
stimme in ihrem wahlkreis in
nordfrankreich ab einer der ärmsten
regionen des landes ihre sozialen
versprechen etwa die kaufkraft zu
stärken finden hier viel zuspruch
tut dietrich alles wird immer teurer mit
marin dorthin werden wir vielleicht
nicht reicher aber das leben wäre
gerechter
ich will einen wechsel in die richtige
richtung sie wäre die beste frankreich
steht vor einer richtungsentscheidung
eine entscheidung bei der auch für
europa viel auf dem spiel steht und für
uns stehende thomas weide und christel
hast dort wo makro und wo le pen hoffen
gleich einen wahlsieg feiern zu können
beginnen wir mal bei ihnen thomas in
einer stunde gibt es die ersten
hochrechnungen wie siegessicher ist
meine makro lager
immerhin will man dann vor seine
anhänger treten wenn es verlässliche
zahlen wenn es ein resultat gibt bei den
anhängern und sondern mitarbeitern die
schon hier sind gibt es eine ganze
bandbreite von stimmung das haben wir
festgestellt in gesprächen das reicht
von verhaltenem optimismus wegen der
letzten umfragen die ganz gut aussahen
für makro bis zu großer nervosität weil
die anhänger makros und seine
mitarbeiter zumindest als katastrophe
empfinden würden wenn le pen gewinne
weil dann ein gänzlich anderes
frankreich auf die weltbühne treten
würde nervös auch weil die zahlen um 17
uhr der wahlbeteiligung etwas niedriger
waren als im ersten wahlgang vor zwei
wochen das meint man könnte le pen zu
gute kommen aber diese bandbreite die ss
große nervosität die noch mindestens
eine stunde anhalten wird und christel
wie zuversichtlich sind die anhänger und
anhängerinnen
lebensnah die 500 handverlesenen gäste
die hier zum wahlabend von marine le pen
geladen sind die tropfen so langsam ein
und die mit denen wir gesprochen haben
die sind sehr zuversichtlich sie glauben
fest an den sieg von marine le pen denn
es ist hier schließlich gelungen ihre
partei als eine feste größe in
frankreich zu fahren kann und sie hat
ein sehr treues und ein sehr stabiles
eine sehr stabile wählerschaft und sie
kann wahrscheinlich auch mit stimmen aus
dem bürgerlichen und auch aus dem ganz
linken lager rechnen also es wird ein
sehr enges rennen und es ist nicht
auszuschließen dass es heute abend noch
eine überraschung gibt dann kann sie
beide nach paris
und erste zahlen aus frankreich gibt es
in einem heute journal spezial ging zehn
nach acht
in die ukraine sollen heute nach angaben
kochs der us außen und der
us-verteidigungsminister kommen das wäre
der hochrangigste besuch aus den usa
seit kriegsbeginn
trotz bitten um eine waffenruhe zum
orthodoxen osterfest hat das russische
militär seine angriffe fortgesetzt wie
auf die hafenstadt odessa wie pablo
sieger live berichtet
ein zerstörtes wohnhaus in odessa
vergangene nacht hat es erneut angriffe
auf die hafenstadt gegeben gestern waren
durch russischen raketen beschuss
mindestens acht menschen gestorben
darunter ein baby erklärte die ukraine
auch aus dem osten des landes werden
wieder angriffe gemeldet diese bilder
zeigen schweres artilleriefeuer offenbar
im don was in der stadt mariupol ist das
stahl werks aus stahl weiter umkämpft
die vereinten nationen fordern eine
sofortige waffenruhe für die stadt
hoffnung liegt auf einem besuch von us
aussenminister blinken und
verteidigungsminister osten in kiew den
hatte der ukrainische präsident für
heute angekündigt kombiniert mit einer
klaren forderung
warum ist es so wichtig dass führende
politiker zu uns kommen pragmatisch
gesagt sie können nicht mit leeren
händen kommen wir erwarten keine
geschenke oder kuchen wir erwarten
bestimmte dinge und spezielle waffen
auch russland rüstet offenbar auf moskau
verstärkt nach ukrainischen angaben
seine truppen in grenznähe mit
kurzstreckenraketen vom typ iskander m
trotz des krieges begehen sie in der
ukraine heute feierlich den orthodoxen
ostersonntag so wie hier in der wladimir
kathedrale in kiew und auch in butter
feiern sie ostern dem orden der wie kaum
ein zweiter symbol für das grauen dieses
krieges geworden ist aus dem glauben
schöpfen sie hoffnung
cdu-chef märz hat die deutsche russland
politik scharf kritisiert auch die
seiner eigenen partei die gesamte außen
und sicherheitspolitik der letzten 20
jahre stehe vor einem scherbenhaufen
sagte er der bild am sonntag alle
verteidigungsminister ministerin hätten
falsche entscheidung getroffen von 2005
bis ende 2021 stunden politiker und
politikerinnen der union an der spitze
des verteidigungsministeriums mit
einem deutlichen votum hat sich der fdp
bundesparteitag für die lieferung auch
von schweren waffen an die ukraine
ausgesprochen generalsekretär bijan djir
sarai mahnte vor dem hintergrund des
krieges und der ukraine ein neues
kapitel in den transatlantischen
beziehungen an dazu gehöre auch ein
neuer anlauf für ein freihandelsabkommen
zwischen der eu und den usa
die linke stellt sich personell neu auf
auf dem parteitag ende juni wird der
gesamte vorstand vorzeitig neu gewählt
die partei ist in einer krise auch wegen
der jüngsten sexismus vorwürfe die
co-vorsitzende hennig will so war am
mittwoch zurückgetreten
bis zum parteitag führt janine wissler
die linke nun allein
nach einer anti israelischen
demonstrationen berlin hat
bundesinnenministerium phaser ein
konsequentes vorgehen gegen
antisemitismus angekündigt in unserer
gesellschaft gibt es keinen platz für
judenfeindlichkeit schrieb sie auf
twitter gestern waren hunderte
pro-palästinensischer demonstrieren
durch die stadt gezogen sie skandierten
israel feindliche und antisemitische
parolen
journalistinnen wurden angegriffen die
polizei ermittelt unter anderem wegen
volksverhetzung und
jetzt kommt ihr zur formel 1 norbert da
hat sich ja heute weltmeister max
verstappen zurückgemeldet mit einem
beeindruckenden siegen im land der
konkurrenten millionen ferraristi
schmollen den titelverteidiger max
verstappen hängt in imola beim vierten
saison grand prix die roten renner ab
und verkürzte den rückstand in der
gesamtwertung auf schall erklär
erheblich sebastian vettel wird achter
es war ein hartes stück arbeit für den
viermaligen weltmeister nicht immer nur
auf der strecke
sich gut an es hat trotzdem ein achter
platz aber für uns muss man ehrlich sein
ist das wie ein sieg mit schumacher
hoffnungsvoll als zehnter gestartet wird
nach diesem dreier vorletzter favorit
erklärt verliert schon am start zwei
plätze und riskiert in der schlussphase
an dritter stelle zu viel wird sechster
max verstarb und sergio perez feiern
gebühren dukaten ferrari die party
zuhause gehörig verdorben
in der fußball bundesliga verliert
aufsteiger vfl bochum 0 zu 2 gegen
augsburg und verpasste es damit sich
vorzeitig den klassenerhalt zu sichern
und das dutzend ist voll der thw kiel
holt sich gegen den sc magdeburg in
hamburg zum zwölften mal den deutschen
handball pokal
um 15 uhr 22 begann die zwölfte
pokalsieger party des thw kiel in einem
intensiven spiel gelang dem sc magdeburg
durch magnus kolorit mit dem 17 zu 16
die letzte führung danach kiel immer
stärker auch durch ihren überragenden
torhüter niklas landin der zweite garant
sandershausen der norweger markierte mit
seinem achten treffer den 28 zu 21
endstand die zebras tanzen der
pokalsieger 20 22 heißt thw kiel
und das war schon hoch sportgeschehen
norbert und wir werfen noch einen kurzen
blick aufs wetter im norden wechseln
morgen sonne und wolken meist bleibt es
trocken sonst regnet es oft teils mit
gewittern die höchsttemperatur liegt
zwischen 10 grad an der ostsee und 17
grad im breisgau
am dienstag regnet es im süden dann wird
es freundlicher und wärmer christian
sievers hat um 21.45 das heute-journal
für sie schön sonntagabend noch